[Music]
do you guys wash your brand-new clothes
no I try not to if they're like intimate
if it's itchy
sometimes shirts are itchy instantly Oh
to soften it up yes often I like a crisp
yeah I preferred them washed he does I
feel like you fit that sorry am i
cutting off now just because when it's
at the store I know my shows been trying
on by 500 other people so I just like it
to be clean
well you don't like the crisp I do like
the crystal what if you like me and you
only pick out ugly clothes that you know
nobody else trade off hello that is
probably nice pretty sure no one tried
that sweater on before we got married
that's what I said he made the joke I
can't are yes ended
I wear them immediately Chia thinks
that's gross she's like so many people
have tried it on she always watch hell
yeah I'm a [ __ ] pig like you bro but
if it doesn't smell like somebody tried
it on and it's bad new chemical yeah I'm
down yeah so I'm a little bit of both
sometimes I like how how like the
material feels brand new like for
example sweaters like this where it's
like nice and fuzzy and stuff like I
don't like washing them cuz then it gets
it's not as soft and fuzzy yeah the
minute you wash it it's a different
sweater that you wash it you don't maybe
cold water and you just air dry it yeah
exactly cold water and then hang dry
that's right clean there we go what I do
what I say yeah I never take my clothes
so directly but maybe I shouldn't but
anyway what do a good sometimes
especially with like underwear that I
buy on Amazon whatever I have 100% it
has to be washed first
well what if it's inside the bag nope
nope nope nope that's going in your vag
yeah yeah nope nope oh yeah there's
chemicals and [ __ ] like I don't want
that on my intimates and I've been to
like manufacturing companies and then
the panties could have dropped on the
ground and they'll pick it up and in
this role and then put into the pot you
guys buy underwear Amazon
yeah like it's like special special I
love Target underwear but sometimes like
the specific like the note knows no
seams theme like yeah sometimes they
don't
that's like [ __ ] scum I guess so it's
a lot of fingers on it so instead of
sewing it that'll create lines if you're
wearing tight pants yeah if you're
wearing tight pants you'll see the lines
seem less they do this new technology
where like they press it so there's like
glued yeah what I know won't be itchy
sometimes it seems causes itchiness Wow
I don't about that you have to protect
of Aegina more get around it's okay so
then it looks like so you don't see
panty lines and [ __ ] that is on dirty
underwear any that's what I'm saying
that's why I put China's had to be
protected yeah yeah sure protect them at
all cost
I don't wear I don't worry I don't do
what I have done the like when you're
out maybe like find the pair in the
hamper that's not that's not dirty you
don't wash your underwear at the hotel
traveling no I do all the time puts me
in a bad mood if I'm not wearing clean
clothes I'm gonna bad I'll just walk
into the shower with your underwear on
and then if you have a dirty t-shirt
that you sweater on if you have pants on
and you know you're gonna be in the
hotel just go in with your clothes on
yeah because they have this string thing
that's what I'm saying that's what it's
what's drinking a little thing in the
shower
oh yeah metal thing that has like a knob
and then you pull it and it's it's a
street get a limit of salt so you go in
and you just [ __ ] your wash your clothes
something out of the whole lot of them
travel like like Gucci hotels have that
because all those women's a Boston Red
Sox with red what Brett sucks are we
talking about here kind that actually
was pretty good joke if you think about
it well cuz the Red Sox probably cheated
and yeah I was right that was just the
inference that Bart somehow cheated on
GL and it's a double meaning yeah
bars okay I wrote that one down
two years ago video I know anyway
there's this girl named Roxy from
England she shared a horrific discovery
horrible it was oh no is it gonna make
me watch my new clothes yes you need to
watch a new club great I'm not doing it
this is new clothes I'm not wide in
watch it oh she don't wash those flames
Jessie on fire of course she has to wash
everything what are their flames I
thought there were hearts when I glanced
at him okay so she but she bought
something from ASOS no she tweeted I
know people wash new clothes before they
wear them but you shouldn't have to wash
them first unlike this supposedly brand
new jumpsuit I bought on ASOS yes this
is someone else's period it's hand wash
only this is what she received oh then
return it you're crash Wow
did she check the box for period stance
or did she uncheck it yeah you got to
specify that it is that when you go to
the mall and you look at the lady's
undies they have the plastic piece that
covers the [ __ ] area yeah yes for the
period discharge we lose yeah just be
protection sexy it's the good one
and sometimes it's the bad one it's what
the bad one I mean not bad but you
really Oh
do you ever look at his like
[Laughter]
that's the way sexier punch back dude
you were like this all day for you make
me lose in my battle on is here is a
waterproof that's why I keep the lining
honest it's about Manny damn that's
nasty yeah so she said that she bought
this on sale so it was $65
she got extra [ __ ] bleeding that's
why for $52
that's why she's like whoa I didn't
expect to have to check it for bodily
fluids first so I put it on Tuesday
morning with the intention of wearing it
to work that day on the backless so I
took it off to put another layer on
underneath it was only then when I laid
it or it was only when I laid it inside
out that I saw the bloodstains she put
it on it's not hers
well done so for a second I thought I
must have started my period early I
hadn't but on closer inspection it was
very obviously someone else's dried
period blood so she tried to contact she
said that it was a nightmare to contact
them it is a string of automated direct
messages with conflicting information so
she could not get a hold of any sort of
customer service and so not until she
tweeted this out back to an SOS customer
service account like the Twitter account
reassured her that she would have loved
ASIS her money back and so what they
ended up doing was they gave her a full
refund and a discount another order and
they will cover the cost to have it
clean that's whatever haven't cleaned
you what the [ __ ] is that idiot that I
can let this [ __ ] go man we realize yeah
they wouldn't check that thank you
especially if it's inside out we realize
you found period blood all over your new
thing we will pay to have it clean I
mean that's whack it is why we just send
you a new one yeah
but it was on sale maybe they didn't
have any more I'll give your store
credit like here's 100 bucks on us oh I
probably money back and send her some
matches then or something well they take
your beer the money back and a discount
on another order so Dan yeah I'm still
not washing my [ __ ] yeah I mean yeah if
anything I'm just gonna check it now I
mean I wear underwear it's a lifestyle
man what do you want I've got to worry
about blood as much as girls do yeah I
mean blood doesn't gross me out like
that
that's [ __ ] nasty here it's [ __ ]
nasty I'm not I'm not saying it's not
but I wouldn't be like oh my god there's
[ __ ] crabs almost what is is
literally the most like the scariest
bodily fluid that's a deal with AIDS
yeah so I'm like in the hospital I
should care I can't you have to assume
that everything has blood on it and
that's like the scariest thing to deal
with in a hospital because anything can
have not just AIDS but it could have
them like the mad cow disease oh yeah
that [ __ ] when when they're surgery for
someone who has my cow disease and
they're doing brain surgery to get rid
of it I don't know how it works but all
those instruments need to be tossed
there's no way you can sterilize it Wow
yes so blood is [ __ ] scary okay well
thank you what about dried blood tip is
that chill yeah I mean it's less scary I
think but it's still scary
I don't like wet blood okay well no I
know blood is bad like wet blood dried
blood okay what what but what if it
wasn't even period blow and if it what
if this girl like you know yeah she got
stabbed in the couch no way dude
that looks like period blood but
straight here flood yeah yeah yeah
there's poopoo that's net that's even
worse oh that's inside out that is
disgusting yeah that's definitely with a
fishing hook and poked herself in the
[ __ ] who's the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] with period like [ __ ] washing
why would you take one of the dirty
[ __ ] yeah so disgusting that's like if
I [ __ ] [ __ ] my own pants and I
returned it back in an Amazon box with
the caca in the pants I bet you people
do that [ __ ]
you people with you I bet you Pete I bet
people but I bet you people do
did you ever see have you ever seen
those things on like there was one thing
they got returned on Amazon or whatever
web said it was and it was like it was a
phone or something that was like shiny
and iPad or some [ __ ] like that and he's
like hey so I opened up my like a huge
like dick like grease print on it like I
liked it like someone took like they're
like it's like a sweaty dick and just
like like like put it like pressed
against the thing with balls to like a
whole brand you go what the [ __ ] did it
have the screen protectors they could
peel the dick off at least yeah [ __ ]
Apple spinners doing some like hello we
would like to pay to have it cleaned
[Music]